alert tough transition somedays welcome
to Washington I'm Bret bear the
countdown is on
in just 12 days President Trump will
have to decide on whether to re-up the
Iran nuclear deal just last week he was
pressed by two allies to stay in the
deal but today a shot in the arm as
Israel's prime minister laid out what he
says is evidence that Iran is pulling
one over on the world when it comes to
Iran's nuclear ambitions correspondent
Connor Pal starts us off tonight from
Jerusalem
good evening Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu may have had an
audience of one in mind
when he made his argument tonight that
the Iran nuclear deal should be scrapped
it's part of his effort to convince
President Trump to a draw from the
agreement which the Prime Minister has
long opposed Netanyahu said quote that
Iran lied big-time as he laid out his
case with 55,000 pages of documents
based on what he calls an extraordinary
intelligence achievement the Iranian
nuclear files obtained by the Israeli
spy agency Mossad saying that Iran can't
be trusted because in the 1990s and
early 2000s Tehran lied about its
nuclear program incited information made
public in the 2011 US National
Intelligence Estimate that Iran
continues to catalogue its past nuclear
program even after the deal Iran
continued to preserve and expand its
nuclear weapons now all for future use
why would a terrorist regime hide and
meticulously catalog its secret nuclear
files if not to use them at a later date
however Wow Netanyahu implied it he did
not lay out a case that Iran has
reconstituted its nuclear program and
secretary defends mattis testified on
Capitol Hill last week that Iran is in
compliance with the current agreement
and praised the oversight provisions in
the deal I will say that it is written
almost with an assumption that Iran
would try to cheat so the verification
what what is in there
is is actually pretty robust even before
Netanyahu spoke iran's Foreign Minister
Javad Zarif mocked Netanyahu for his
2012 United Nations General Assembly
speech writing on Twitter the boy who
can't stop crying wolf is at it again
undeterred by cartoon Fiasco at the UN
GA you can only fool some of the people
so many times the debate over the
nuclear agreement comes as tensions are
heating up on the ground in Syria
between Israel and Iran for the second
time in about two weeks Israeli Jets
reportedly struck out Iranian targets
inside Syria Brett
Carnivale live in Jerusalem connor thank
you